this is the Fox News Alert President
Trump just tweeting that Secretary of
Defense James Madison will be retiring
at the end of February Lisa what do you
make of it I find it sad I mean I love
general mattis I mean this is a tough
guy I think a lot of people like one of
the biggest criticisms well I guess he's
not literally listening to his generals
regarding Syria but one of the biggest
criticisms was that he wasn't going to
follow the advice of his advisors and he
wasn't going to surround himself with
necessarily the best people and I think
in choosing general mattis that helps
give a lot of confidence to naysayers
and people that were concerned about the
kind of decisions this president would
make and so I find it you know really
disappointing said that general mattis
is leaving particularly at a time where
we're dealing with North Korea we've got
China on the rise as well
so Jason the thing is I mean President
Trump recently said Oh Madison's like a
Democrat or son remember that and now
you have him defying the president
defying mattis's suggestions with regard
to pulling those troops out of Syria
what do you make of it look the country
will owe a lot to general mattis for
decades of service in the Marines
serving tours in Afghanistan and Iraq
he'll be revered for a long and storied
career if there's one great pic that I
think the president made early on in his
cabinet it was general mattis I think on
both sides of the aisle so much respect
for this man and what he's done one of
the quotes I recently read it from him
but I won't get that quote exactly right
but he was basically engage your brain
before you engage your guns and for a
military leader to think like that talk
like that but to be able to back it up
is inspirational there's a lot to learn
from this man we got to thank him for
his service and I gave it ently he'll be
there still as the Secretary of Defense
Intel February general perio what are
you thinking no I'm no general at all
Ivan I cannot hold a candle to him I
think that you saw that the Pentagon
actually worked very well was run very
well for the last two years and general
Kelley I'm sorry
general mattis was able to fulfill
president Trump's direction when he
asked for troops to go to the border for
support down there and he did that and
really pushback on media criticism or I
should say just media but democratic
criticism
and he was willing to do that and he
really went to the math test for the
president but now I think that the the
White House is going to have once again
a big nomination fight on their hands my
son's a fight but it'll just be an issue
right I'll take up because they have now
the AG at Department of Justice and DoD
but I would say something about this
move this has been rumored for a while
and the demise of Jim mattis had been
rumored like you could report it every
week somebody said he was going to be
out the door but I will say that if you
think back to the Obama administration
everyone who was the national security
team for President Obama when they left
and wrote their books every single one
of them Kerry Panetta gates Clinton all
said the president did not listen to us
on Syria that he didn't listen to us you
didn't take our advice but they stayed
right look obviously in this case
general mattis is saying okay like if
you're not going to listen to me and I
can't be a part of this and I can't be
behind this I'm gonna have to go